this is a production of Cornell
University
hi this Frank Rossi for the Cornell
turfgrass video log and when here at the
bethpage State Park in early May of 2011
and today we're thinking about annual
bluegrass seed head suppression most
guys now are using the proxy primo
combination and finding that you know
timing is very critical for the first
application should they make a second
application and here we are in early man
I think we're just starting to get into
that early flush of seed heads now we
have some greens out here that have
gotten to application some that have
gotten a single application and right
now in early May we're still seeing
about sixty to eighty percent
suppression which is really all you can
expect from that type of material that
combination we have seen a lot more
success with embark and primo it gives
you a little bit of a later timing and
we've seen a little bit higher level of
seed head suppression now we are seeing
significant breakthrough aunties and
fairways but still our proxy treated
greens even with a single application
are doing exceptionally well so if you
can get that timing pretty well nailed
down which you can access on our
forecast website through the cornell
turfgrass website you can find out when
ideal timings for these seed head
suppression products are and hopefully
I'll have some excellent success with
that program this is Frank Rossi for the
Cornell turfgrass video log this has
been a production of Cornell University
on the web at cornell edu